hey girls did what if you order a
virtual pizza with extra sausage well
that's cool toy what's that do nope nope
nope nope hey guys I'm Brent Rose writer
and pumping love muscle even though it's
so young it's barely legal we already
know virtual reality porn is going to be
big so big if you haven't already gotten
a load of it at least you know the
Internet has gone wild for reaction
videos but what you probably haven't
peaked as an internal look at how VR
porn is actually made so today we're
spreading the subject wide open and
going deep won't you come inside me come
inside with me keep your chest take one
I'm just going to drop you right into no
soft landings great okay and we're going
in okay and there's just a big gaping
butthole right in front of me I feel
like a proctologist right now I think
you probably have a better view so
you're seeing like you can look up and
down left and right and then we are
gonna start shooting in 360 as well like
maybe an orgy shoot so you can let yeah
choose your own adventure but our goal
is this we wanted to give like some
really interesting experiences and so 3d
and doing stereoscopic 3d was really
important for us and we decided to start
with just like a 3d 180 viewpoint
because that really fit with with our
set soaring like we already have a
director behind us and lights behind us
so this was able to like take that to
the next level so this is our next rig
our next camera that we're using this
one you're gonna get about a 228
viewpoints so you're gonna be able to
look way more around the room and I am a
woman now she's now going down on me
ha ha ha so that's what it looks like
from this side so in this one we have
this beautiful woman who was huge as a
dom and we wanted you to be low and
underneath her
she's like larger-than-life oh she has a
penis it kind of it forces your
perspective oh she's doing the Silicon
Valley tip to tip method
yep that's efficient thank you for
taking me to that world now I want to
see how you guys create that world
so you're sort of blazing trails here at
kink 4br is that right I feel like we
are yes what are the differences in
terms of how you approach shooting vr
porn in your standard porn there's a
general vocabulary that already exists
for a virtual reality it's basically the
Wild West as a performer how does doing
vr differ from like your standard 2d
point instead of like being right up in
front and connected like this I almost
call it the backbend you have to be so
far back in order for you just to see my
face any position is gonna be
drastically different when you're
shooting VR I had trouble keeping my
legs in so it doesn't go out of the view
of the viewer and break like the reality
of it we do a lot of rehearsal I don't
want there to be very many cuts in the
video itself because you don't have cuts
in real life yeah Martin Scorsese
approached apart yeah we do a lot of
blocking how to keep their body and
frame in a 180 world it's just like
we're all collectively remembering this
new set of rules together where do you
guys see it going I think like the
future of porn is interactive and much
more personal I could see a lot more
porn stars be more curious about
watching themselves in virtual reality I
like never watch my own clips but I
watched my sheet that I did it's like
looking as a person I was like oh my god
this is what it's like Who I am and
we're not gonna be able to hide every
single flaw it's almost a whole new
level of vulnerability for like exposing
yourself on camera dimensionally this is
the picture look pretty in this
direction we're real I think that's good
though I think so especially for women
out there it's gonna make them feel a
lot better about watching it so they'll
be like oh that girl looks kind of like
me I'm really curious to see how you
guys make it can you show me a little
bit of what a shoot would look like
today we're trying our first 360 vr
shoot so it's gonna be an experiment
with us and with you my mom predicted
this would happen so there's seven
cameras here this is a pretty flexible
rig there's one two three four five six
seven point out the post-production
software allows us to sync and we have
to roll certain things so it sinks I'm
gonna show you the best places to be
we're shooting with this camera we have
our willing victim here what's important
to know about this camera is don't get
too close to it you can get about three
feet are you basically like trying to
keep things like off the scenes exactly
and the closer your are to the camera
when you cross the camera it's more
obvious that they're scenes so we call
that parallax ready girls
[Music]
yet that was fun it's a it's interesting
to see porn from that side so the VR
footage is all shot how do you make it
into something that can be viewed on a
oculus or something like that
the general idea is to take that fisheye
footage and map it to an equi
rectangular dome so when you put the
headset on you're looking around in this
full world so here's some footage the
program will then you know map it into a
dome for us well I know what's going on
my Christmas list so what did we learn
here today well making VR porn is way
more complicated than we first imagined
from dealing with weird camera angles to
performing in awkward positions hiding
the crew lighting challenges and a
post-production nightmare you really see
all the work that goes into it and yet
when you're watching it and that fourth
wall has been stripped away and you feel
like you're in the room you really get
the sense that this is where the
industry has been ahead but what do you
think let us know in the comments below
subscribe to wire it if you haven't
already with all that being said there's
really only one thing left to do
[Music]
oh hey ladies did what do you order a
virtual pizza with extra sausage we
don't want any pizza oh those are fun
toys
what are those do